question we got an email from TrueRive about a deal setting in your model F117 correct so this month if you
send in if you have an F117 so they came out with the F122 about three years ago or so so most
everybody on here I think has an F122 if you do have an F117 you can upgrade this to an F122 for
$1500 during February so just call TrueRive you can upgrade it what's the advantage is I'm upgrading
so I have a number of F117s at my office for use my office my kids my never I have an F117
the F122 at home I'm upgrading it to an F122 simply because I do think that there may be a time
where the F117 might not be supported they might not support three pairs on it so I think if you
do have an F117 that was a perfect time to upgrade it for $1500 you just send it in to TrueRive they turn
around and send you a brand new F122 for $1500 plus $35 shipping and I think that's just a deal of
a deal right now they're just I don't know where it's a great deal so I would suggest you do it
I am a gaining weight so bad it doesn't stop so when you have weight gain usually
cancer patients don't have weight gain this person is doing real well probably into remission and
but what you do want to look at with weight gain is a number of things so
you know again I'm not a weight loss specialist so but definitely look and get your thyroid
readings back will thyroid panel we talked about what that the definition of that is
and first he's talking about everything that they're doing and you know they and they're still
gaining weight so it's just how is this possible it's very very difficult one of the things with
increase weight gain with everything you're doing you want to look at possible food sensitivities
so and the reason why is that if you have food sensitivities hidden food sensitivities
and you're eating those food you're causing this inflammation even though you're doing eating
really good food so the way you have to get that done is you have to do a Cyrex array it's called
array 10 that's what you would really want to do with a case like this